this is fp is the new oop i'm michael
snoyman and let's dive in
i've said things like this at many
different talks i've given in the past
and i don't think people really believe
because i'm a hassle guy and haskell guy
obviously that means i'm a functional
programmer i don't really consider
myself much of a functional programmer
so that's uh it's a funny thing to be
saying at a functional programming
conference but we're going to start off
that way anyway
so i've been working 12 plus years
professionally with haskell a few years
before that non-professionally
i also use plenty of other languages
that i would cons or i write code that i
would consider functionally inspired in
other languages this includes recently
i've been working with russ and
typescript in addition to haskell
years ago i even wrote some java code
that i would uh like church encoding and
data types really weird stuff
uh and i used to do that in uh
as well
and it's all functional programming
inspired i still don't consider myself a
functional programmer and one of the
main reasons is something that i've said
many times i really don't know what what
a functional programming language is
and now we're going to go into a very
weird direction
we're going to talk about let's about
psychology
i batted around the idea for this talk
long before i knew i was going to be
giving this talk with a friend of mine
adam mcauliffe
and he gave me an eye-opening analogy
that i wanted to share for this
people may be familiar with freud freud
was a huge pioneer in the field of
psychology he basically created
psychoanalysis and that's based off of
you know two minutes of reading
wikipedia about him
but these days if you say freud and you
talk about freud's theories people don't
bring up all of the incredible
innovations he he came up with they
don't ascribe these great things to
freud instead you hear these
relatively speaking corner cases of
freud's philosophy you hear about things
like the oedipus complex or a freudian
slip and i will avoid making some jokes
here even though they're very funny
because i'm being recorded but maybe
offline you can tell some freudian jokes
the question is why why is this the case
and adam had a great insight
the stuff that he got right freud now
these things are transparent to people
because they've become ubiquitous to our
understanding of psych
anything he got right people just accept
as part of mainstream psychology and the
things that maybe are a little weird a
little off the beaten track those are
the only things that stick around as
being freudian
so keep that idea in mind i think it's a
great analogy and a great framing device
and now we're going to jump back in and
talk about what is functional
programming
there's not really a i mean there are
lists you can again you can go to
wikipedia you can go to other places and
you can get an idea of what makes
something a functional programming
language
and you get some of these ideas like
higher order functions
immutability
declarative coding which
frankly i think is uh
is a cop-out on the functional
programming part everyone claims that
they're doing some level of declarative
coding we like to claim it
lazy generators are typically part of
functional programming i'm a half
skeleton primarily and in haskell we
obviously have lazy data structures and
we use lazy lists as our lazy generators
many functional programming languages
have rich type systems
and we'll get dead and type classes
those two really go together
this is a fair list to define functional
programming maybe and if you come from a
different language like closure or
something and you're upset about things
like rich type systems don't worry the
list is not intended to be authoritative
let's go back in time a little bit
further though
before haskell came along before the
functional programming revolution that
many of us are a part of
you had languages like c
and if you have a language like c
we can ask the basic question today is
it a good language and i think many
people here
are going to say no c is an absolutely
horrifically terrible language
when you write c you are do everything
you are doing is based on pointers
there are no generics you have to write
either
void star you have to coerce types all
over the place or you have to write
multiple copies of functions in order to
make things work us functional
programmers love genetics
generally
manual memory management that's that's a
thing of the past that's something that
you know silly people write because all
of us use garbage collection these days
and that's obviously better
and c has relatively speaking very weak
abstraction capabilities
and i think this is a many of us would
say that this is a fair assessment of
the c programming language
but i'm going to tell you we're all
wrong
instead of asking to see a good language
let me ask a different question
why was c invented where did it come
from
many people have used the phrase for c
that it is a portable assembler it's
better than writing assembly because
assembly is the thing that people were
writing for that kind of code beforehand
c brought many innovations c brought
forward the idea of portability
previously if you wanted to have code
that ran on multiple different
architectures you had to write it
multiple times now with c you could
write the code once and have a compiler
compile it down to multiple different
architectures that's a huge step forward
instead of having to write jumps and
comparisons and all these other things
at the assembly level
c introduced control structures things
like a for
a while
to completely change the way that you
write code
c added in type safety which seems to
contradict what i was just saying that c
has weak types and not great abstraction
capabilities no generics but when you
compare c to what came before it
the type safety is amazing
c allowed you to have code reads it
became much easier to define functions
to find the libraries and use them
across multiple projects and as much as
we today beat up on c for this horrible
evil manual memory management memory
management in c is leaps and bounds
better than anything that came before it
so it's interesting in this way of
looking at things is all of these points
these five points every single one of
them looks like a weakness of c compared
to modern programming languages but when
c came out every single one of them was
a huge step forward from what came
before us
let's go on a little bit further in
history
talk about how much object oriented code
sucks
we're at an fp conference therefore we
all agree that oop is dead op is evil
it's the worst thing that ever existed
and again i did you know five minutes of
research and i looked online and i
wanted to see what are people
complaining about oop these days
one phrase i saw that came up is it's a
big blob of global mutable state
class hierarchies make no sense i think
we all
anyone any one of us who went through
learning java or c plus plus at some
point you remember learning about how an
animal class has subclasses of cat and
dog and you tell them to speak and they
say
woof but none of that actually makes any
sense in real life code it's a weird
example that doesn't actually add up to
real life
we also know that java does ridiculous
funny things like abstract class bean
factory factory and oop encourages
really bad abstractions and all of these
are things that fp does way better than
oop
and that's why we hate oop
and why we've moved on to better
paradigms like functional programming
hopefully some people especially scholar
people some people are getting their
blood boiling in the audience right now
feel free to feel that way because
we're going to take a u-turn
my claim and the whole point of this
talk really is that there's a lot more
to oop than the things i just described
and you may be able to connect the dots
with why i brought up freud at the
beginning what i was saying about c
maybe you're going to see the pattern at
this point so let's dive into this there
is much more to op than these ugly
points that i just picked on
op said we should combine data and code
together which you may like it you may
not like it but it's actually a very
common practice
in many languages
before as i mentioned c if you wanted to
do something
on multiple different data types you had
to define a function multiple different
times oop really pushed the idea of mean
overloading which
theoretically at least reduces the
cognitive overlap
the cognitive load of writing code
oop was massive on encapsulation you
should be able to hide away complexity
inside functions inside classes inside
things whatever the thing the level of
encapsulation is op was really pushing
the idea of good abstractions we in the
fp world often look at oop and say oh
those are stupid bad abstractions but
really if you look at what oop was
coming from
it was really innovating in a good
direction generics became a big part of
oop and in the functional programming
world we use that all the time and one
of the jokes that i've heard repeatedly
in the haskell world is you can solve
any problem in haskell by adding another
type variable we love these things
and also programming to interfaces a
massive part of oop don't write your
code against some concrete type write it
against the interface it's a common
pattern in java
when you hear people criticizing oop you
don't see them pointed to any of these
six points
not usually at least
why is that
that's because these concepts are the
ones that won
and now we can finally in a programming
talk i can actually show you some code
and i apologize in advance code is few
and far between these slides so enjoy it
while you can
this is a
idiomatic great implementation of the
sum function in haskell and for those
who aren't familiar with it i'm going to
just step through it very briefly
the sum function says
that it works on a t of a
t has to implement some kind of type
class foldable which for our purposes we
can look at that as a container of
things and num a means that a has to be
something which is numeric in nature and
if you give some a container of a's it
gives you back an a
so for example if you give it a list of
ins it'll give you back a single lint or
if you give it a vector events or if you
give it a map that contains incident and
so on and so forth the point is it's
going to take a whole bunch of events
and collapse them down and our
implementation is pretty interesting
we're going to leverage the fold map
function which is generic on anything
that's foldable it's actually also using
the semi-group or actually monoid
type class under the surface we are
going to use this new type wrapper
called sum to say the way that i want to
combine these things together is with
addition and then i'm going to use i'm
going to use function composition to
combine that concept together with get
sun to unwrap the sum wrapper
let's talk about how this what this code
is doing
it is programming to interfaces that
sounds a lot like oop doesn't it num and
foldable are both interfaces nowhere in
here did i say anything about lists ins
doubles or anything else
we're dealing with abstractions the
concept of a monologue the concept of
sun these are
much more abstract they're great
abstractions they work all over the
place you can write really interesting
code as a result of these abstractions
this is a little bit tongue-in-cheek but
you can we've also encapsulated a lot of
the complexity here
uh people who are really into oop
encapsulation will probably yell at me
and say i'm misusing the term
encapsulation but you know i'm the one
talking i can say whatever i want
some is really hiding away some
complexity of the idea of being able to
add things together through combination
that's kind of cool and of course
everything here is based off of name
overloading the sum function now works
on
any combination of num types and
foldable types the get the fold map in
there works on any kind of combination
of monoids and foldable some works on
any kind of model so instead of having
to define things multiple different
times we're able to define this one
function based off of reusable
components
so i would argue that this piece of code
which i think everyone would have
any most has colors because you can't
say all has colors for anything most
task scalers would say
this is really good idiomatic haskell
code and i'd argue it is following
object-oriented principles
which really
means people are going to be pissed at
me right now
yes i'm being very fast and loose with
definitions on both the fp side and the
oop side
and my points here are not to argue
about any of these specific definitions
later on i'm sure in some some uh some
other form people yell at me on twitter
about this which is great i love getting
nailed up on twitter
but
let's go the real question about this is
not what are the exact definitions
my question is why do so many of us see
we seem to despise oop why is there an
attack and a hatred of oop in the
functional programming world when we
seemingly adhere to many of the
principles at least on some level
so let's review what i've said so far in
this talk to review the history
we had a language called c and it made
significant improvements on the
programming status quo which was
assembly at the time it introduced new
concepts new abstractions it was great
and made made coding much better
many
most maybe almost maybe all of those
improvements were then adopted by
languages that came later you don't see
a lot of it you don't notice that
because it became so common
that every other language was doing
those things
but
some of those things that were left
behind some of those things were not
adopted some of the things that weren't
great things like having to manually
manage memory those were left behind you
either got garbage collection you got
rai you got some other techniques
and all those things that got left
behind we modern programmers people who
grew up in a world already with
object-oriented programming or
functional programming in it
we look back at c and all we see is the
crappy parts of it that were left behind
oop stands on the grave of c to some
extent even though he's alive and
kicking
and op followed exactly the same pattern
it went ahead and it made a bunch of
improvements
that really i was actually just
beginning to learn programming at the
time that oop was really taking off in
industry
and oop came along it introduced these
concepts that solved real world problems
that existed the things that oop nailed
and got completely correct
all the future languages picked up on
and can you continue to do
so
uh and now when we look back at oop
especially us in the functional
programming world we don't see the cool
great innovations that improve the
status quo we instead see the crappy
parts that we don't like stuck behind
the crazy design patterns the weird
abstractions
so i'm just going to read over some of
the chat messages while i sip some of my
coffee a little bit and see what people
love to say
yep
yeah i agree this is all about
differences from what came before it
yeah that is the pattern that i'm
getting at here
okay
so now let's talk about fp
this is my personal favorite fp features
and
might look cherry-picked
but this is actually it
i love the fact that when i'm writing
haskell code i have strong types i have
adt's algebraic data types
that is such a huge step forward from
every other thing that i use beforehand
i never want to use a language without
those ever again
cheap new typewrappers are another
massive part of my
my haskell and functional programming
experience i love them i think they make
code quality much better
pattern matching is so much better than
other kinds of ways of doing
conditionals type classes are a smarter
easier to work with approach
than interfaces or having to do
extensions see you know abstract classes
any of the other approaches that we had
previously
so i think these are great
and what's really interesting about this
is the two other languages that i've
been working with the most recently rust
and typescript
both have
if not all most of these features i'm
not sure if you can really argue that
typescript that typescript has type
classes it does have the other three and
if you just squint and change the names
a little bit rust has all four of these
at least to some extent
and what's even more interesting
very few people would really make the
claim that roster typescript are fp
languages so what we're seeing is at
least for me personally what i consider
the wonderful pieces of fp
have already been adopted by new
languages that have come out recently
relatively recently
and they don't consider themselves fp
we all know that imperative languages
are evil let's look at how bad this c
code is yay we get some more code on the
screen
so this is c
we have this mutable variable here
called total we have another mutable
variable here called i
we have short circuiting meaning we are
not going to continue running this loop
that's another bad practice according to
most functional programming standards
we are mutating total again we have to
keep track of our loop explicitly and we
print things at the end
now everyone can probably stare at this
for a little bit
and you can figure out what this code is
doing but it's not exactly intuitive you
can see here that we're kind of looping
from the number i is going to be the
numbers 1 through 10. not too difficult
to see
you can squint here and you can see okay
well let's see
i modulus 2 not equal to 0 not equal to
0 means that it's going to be odd yeah
it's going to be odd then we're going to
continue that means we're going to short
circuit so we're not doing the odd
numbers we're doing the even numbers now
and here we're going to take those even
numbers multiply them multiply them by 3
and add them to total okay
not terribly complex and it's obviously
a contrived example it's in fact it's a
contrived example i've used in many of
my talks in the past to demonstrate fp
principles
but it works
let's compare this what i consider
convoluted c code
to beautiful fpm haskell
and here
i believe that you could take a
non-programmer show them the screen and
they could get a pretty good idea right
off the bat about what this code is
doing
we can see right here we are iterating
over the numbers 1 through 10. 1.10
someone who didn't know what that meant
i could explain it very easily
filter even cool
map times 3. we are now going to apply
times three we're going to triple every
single value that was even in the map
and then we are going to sum them up
this is r this is the kind of code where
fp really shines it's a clean separation
of all the logical components of our
code
another thing that's nice
every single bit of this is fully
immutable i never had to mutate a
variable sure under the surface the
computer is actually mutating things
in memory it's mutating registers i
don't have to worry about that my code
is cool pure immutable
i have sensible combinators instead of
having to reinvent inside a for loop the
concept of mapping and summing i'm able
to reuse functions that already exist
and i'm lazily generating values i don't
have to worry about allocating an entire
array
instead haskell is going to lazily
produce these values and if you turn on
optimizations
you're not even going to end up getting
any allocation all of this is going to
run in a tight inner loop and that's
really beautiful
so that's functional programming but
let's go ahead and move over to a
non-functional programming language
previously we looked at c and we saw
imperative languages are evil
let's look at another imperative
language
rust
rust we are going to read the code
backwards to the way that we did in
haskell
but it turns out we are functionally
doing ident exactly the same thing
we are using one dot dot equals ten so
slightly different syntax but basically
the same thing
we use the filter function
rust doesn't have a built-in even
function but
that looks close enough
we're then going to map
uh
rust doesn't have partial function
application of partial operator
application or uh
or sections
so instead we have to do an explicit
closure that's not too bad and some
so sure it's a little bit more verbose
than the haskell code
but conceptually it's identical
right now if you go to a row station and
you bring up this code they will
probably refer to this as functional
style
which is cool they're still giving a nod
in the direction of us cool fp people
who came before them and
came up with all these great ideas of
functional programming but very quickly
this is simply being called idiomatic
rust code and that's an important
distinction people aren't saying i'm
writing fp and rust people are saying
i'm writing rust the correct way
by contrast you could do this exact bit
of code rust
the the imperative way the bad way
this is now functionally basically
identical to what we had previously
in the c code i used a while loop
instead of the for loop because for
loops are slightly different than rust
but it's still the same kind of concept
of short circuiting mutation etc
if you write this code in rust and you
go and you share it with say the rust
subreddit
i put
quite a bit of money down that someone
is going to critique it and say you
shouldn't write it that way
you're doing things the uh the
imperative you the mutable way you
should it's not
it's not idiomatic rust it's not the
right way to write rust code
and that's very interesting
just for the record
you can write the same kind of crappy
mutating code in haskell if you're
really determined one of the nice things
about haskell is that it makes it really
difficult to write code in the wrong way
like this
so
what's my point
functional programming has introduced
amazing new concepts to the programming
world
and i believe we are all much better off
for the fact that fp has influenced
what's going on in the world
however
the best parts have already been stolen
by other languages
when i got started writing haskell code
12 years ago most languages didn't have
easy ways of doing lambdas lambdas are
now all over the place i believe both
java and c plus have added lambdas in
the past 10 years
javascript had
what is it that script 6
to provide a simple lambda kind of
syntax
and everyone uses them you don't have to
feel uh embarrassed when you use this
kind of thing
mapreduce when i first started teaching
or teaching or at least talking about
haskell in general i repeatedly
got this got this pushback of but why
would i need to why would i want to
learn that concept i could just write a
four loop people legitimately believe
that using for loops instead of map
reduce fold
all of these kinds of concepts was much
easier to just learn the for loop once
i've not heard anyone make that claim in
the past five years at least and that's
because the concept has gone all over
the place when i was reviewing a
co-worker's typescript code recently
i'm not i'm not any kind of an expert on
react i used a little bit and i was a
little amused to notice that for each
and map are just commonplace and the
idiomatic way to solve problems and
react these days
i have a particularly fun story though
about javascript and the result type
so i work here at fpcomplete and
fpcomplete started off exclusively as a
haskell shop and we've added additional
things that we that we do over the years
one of the things that we now provide is
we provide rust services
we were contacted by a team of
javascript developers who were working
on some front-end code
and they came to us completely for our
rust expertise
they didn't even know that we were a
haskell shop they didn't know we had
anything to do with function program
and they started describing this problem
that they had where they were trying to
use a rust library call out to it from
their javascript code and one of the
issues that they were running into is
they saw this weird result type and they
didn't understand how they were supposed
to deal with the results or even why
results was a part of the api
in rust
so i started explaining to them what
result is and for those who aren't
familiar familiar
results is basically like the either
type in haskell it is an either okay or
error
uh adt enum some type whatever you want
to call it
and it allows you to do proper error
handling in rust i get about 30 45
seconds into this explanation and the
javascript developers interrupt me and
they say oh you mean results as a monad
which was shocking because my entire
career up until that point in functional
programming had been
monads are evil and scary and terrifying
and no one wants to learn them and it's
the reason why people are avoiding
functional programming and all of a
sudden out of left field i had people
who were not functional programmers not
familiar with haskell didn't even know
that i was familiar with haskell and
they considered monad to be such a
commonplace topic that they could use
that to explain what previously i would
have thought would have been the simpler
concept result so
we can definitely see the influence of
fp has gone deep
into industry
so we're going to have a next generation
i consider putting in some kind of a
star trek meme at this point but anyway
we're going to have a next generation of
programs
these this next generation of
programmers are learning languages where
the functional programming concepts are
built in from the beginning unlike
unlike myself unlike other people of my
generation who started off with
imperative or object-oriented
programming and then they had to go
ahead and they had to learn functional
programming concepts
people today who are learning javascript
are learning about math right from the
beginning people learning java and even
c plus plus perhaps they're learning all
these things from the get go
4-h
is 4-h immutable by default kind of
coding standards pattern matching all of
this is considered normal programming
not some kind of weird fp thing that we
have to do instead
as a result
fp-focused languages languages like
haskell or scala
or closure or other kinds of languages
we're no longer going to stand out from
the pack based off of these features
someone comes up to me at a javascript
conference and they say hey
uh i heard about this hassle thing why
should i use it and i say well it's got
immutability i'll say yes so does rust
say oh well um it's got closure yeah so
does javascript none of these things are
really going to go ahead and help things
out what did naresh say
hotel
for people who can't see the uh who are
watching the recording hotel monad dot i
i n so apparently monads have really uh
taken off in industry
okay
instead
like uh like imperative and
object-oriented programming before
fp languages are now going to stand out
not for the cool innovations that have
taken the world by storm and everyone is
using them because they're so great
instead
i predict 10 years from now maybe even
less
people coming out of school people
starting to write code for the first
time they're going to look back on
languages like haskell for the things
that other languages haven't adopted
so what are those things
just small some you know subset
laziness
haskell
even within the functional programming
community is somewhat unique in being a
lazy language
lazy generators things like python's
generators or
rust iterators those are still lazy
generators and they're great but the
general concept of having a lazy
language that's going to stand out and
we actually i actually already see this
when i'm training haskell
a lot of the time we have to almost
become apologists for the fact that
haskell is a lazy language because it
does stand out as a weird thing that for
many people makes code much more
difficult to work with
purity is something that
again i'm mostly speaking haskell purity
is something that many other languages
haven't picked up on now there are some
concepts in general that people say hey
you should you know your small functions
should be pure functions people
understand some kind of advantages of
purity but the idea that we should have
iomatic code in order to have
complete referential transparency
throughout the code
i can't really think of another of a
mainstream language that has picked up
on that and standardized on that
higher counted types i actually think
higher kind of types are a great feature
that other languages should pick up
because i don't think it's a
particularly uh complex thing and i
think it's the power to weight ratio on
it is pretty good
but many other languages do not pick it
up and i see the impact of that when
people see haskell and they have to
learn higher kind of types they get a
little bit scared
similarly to the way that they used to
get scared about math and reduce well
these days they're not scared of that
they're scared of higher kind of types
category theoretic nomenclature with
some exceptions like monad which is
actually caught on
you don't see people embracing things
like semi groups and semi and
and whatever
all the other things that come from
category theory
those things are now becoming the
reputation of languages like haskell
and so we end up in a situation where
the most powerful features at least in
my opinion the most powerful features of
fp have already been adopted and
embraced by other languages and the
feature is that maybe these are good
maybe these are bad
depends on your standpoint on these
but these features are now becoming the
reputation of fp and fp is beginning to
lose some of its allure because it
doesn't carry the same power that it
used
to so what do we do about all this
they've stolen all of our great ideas
functional programming can no longer
compete in the marketplace because
everyone is already doing it what do we
do about it
some language ecosystems have
experienced this in the past and they've
taken the complaint about it approach
we can run around and we can say you
know haskell did that first we had list
comprehensions before everyone else i
don't know why people love python list
comprehensions haskell did it better
also we could say no no that's better in
ml or it's not as elegant as it is
installer
please
please
let's not do this this is a wonderful
way to ostracize people and get
developers to think oh it's those salty
functional programming people i don't
want anything to do with them let's go
off and have fun without them because
they suck so i advise against taking the
complaint together about a route
another thing we could do is we could
simply admit defeat
we could say that functional programming
languages now are a waste of time all
the good features got stolen other
languages have taken over time to just
jump on to whatever other language
bandwagon exists
i think this is completely missing the
big picture of what's going on
something that i think is much closer to
the mark
is instead of defeat we declare victory
the fact is for many of us the point
wasn't about our
particular pet language winning the
point is we want to have better software
development in the world in general
and on that
basis i would say that we have actually
done that with fp the great concepts of
fp have made better programming
languages out there in the world that's
what we actually care about we want
software development to be a better
discipline we succeeded by making these
great concepts popular
and therefore and this is the part that
i'm not actually advocating that this is
the bad part of the message here we can
just let the fe languages quietly die
off in a corner while new better
languages take over
it's closer but i'm not quite satisfied
with that being the takeaway from this
here's something that i actually believe
we can do one thing is declare our niche
our niche
one thing that i absolutely believe is
that haskell is one of the greatest
languages that exists for proper
concurrent programming
stm software transactional memory
is basically unrivaled in any other
language haskell does a better job of it
in my opinion at least because it has
security built in from the beginning
purity and referential transparency
makes stm an incredibly powerful tool
the ability to write concurrent complex
concurrent code with a library like
async i don't see that
getting
getting passed up anywhere else either
you've combined those two things
together you can really define a great
niche or haskell excels beyond other
languages
parser combinators i still believe that
that the greatest parsers i've ever
written the easiest way to write parsers
have always been with a parser
combinator library like parsec
edsls
still
best in class is a language like haskell
that allows you to define arbitrary
operators that has great support to this
kind of a setup
point being that fp languages still
excel beyond the features that have been
adopted by others and we should be
playing to that advantage if someone
comes to us and says why should i be
using fp why should i be using haskell
or scholar or something else
we can't simply we can no longer simply
talk about the cool features like
mapping and immutability we have to talk
about these more avant-garde these
things that are on the more cutting edge
that really give us our advantage
another great takeaway
that i don't think many of us notice but
i see it in my training work is that the
barriers to entry
are greatly reduced
when i first started learning haskell
and later when i started teaching
haskell
there was a massive barrier to entry
i have told a story a few times of the
first the first thing i ever tried to
write in haskell beyond toy programs was
some kind of a web service and i was
using the cgi package at the time this
is
way long ago and cgi for those who are
wondering it's not nothing to do with uh
with images cgi is the common gateway
interface and it was the way that old
web applications were written and tied
into uh web servers like apache
so back when i got started i remember
reading the documentation on the cgi
package
and it used monads and i had no idea
what a monad was and i
broke i bashed my head against a brick
wall for a while i broke my brain and
eventually i got some kind of working
code and i got a web application to
launch and yes
okay now it's time to use a database
so i go to the docs and it says
something about databases great and it
says to use a database you'll need a
monad transformer and i do not
exaggerate when i say i close the
computer right then and i took a break
from haskell for the next six months
because i could not
face the thought of having to learn a
monad transformer at that time
this kind of learning curve
still exists to some extent for haskell
but it's not nearly as steep as it used
to be like i mentioned with monads
monads are now a common topic out there
in the world it's not weird to have to
teach someone about recursion and
mapping and reducing all of those are
common topics these days
another thing that we can go ahead and
we can take advantage of is that
functional programming languages are a
great cell to normal programs if you are
out there writing day-to-day javascript
code you may end up being a better
javascript developer if you learn
functional programming languages you can
take those concepts and bring them back
and write better javascript code as a
result
[Music]
we can also learn from the market
fp
has been a petri dish for new ideas some
of that has to do with its academic
background some of it has to do with the
kinds of people that are adopted that
adopt fps so some level of selection
lines
some of the ideas that we have created
in this petri dish of fp have flourished
and i've mentioned many of them but as
i've also mentioned many of them have
been ignored
i may offend some people here but i'm
going to claim we should not
automatically stick to our guns if we
have come up with some ideas that we
think are cool
but the rest of industry is looking at
it and saying now we're not ready to
accept it
we should we shouldn't
automatically believe that the rest of
industry is correct
but we should at least be willing to
learn
and say maybe they have a point
and finally
i think one of our takeaways should
definitely be humility
unlike the way i started off this talk
saying that op sucks and c sucks and all
these other things
and fp is just a better way of writing
code let's change the tone
fp languages stand on the shoulders of
giants all of those innovations and
improvements that have come before us we
have adopted and we have absorbed into
these fp languages
we should recognize that fp has a
history of learning from others and i
think at this point we should be going
out there and seeing what ideas should
we be stealing from other languages it's
not fair that everyone else gets to
steal our great ideas and not the other
way around we should recognize other
languages and other ecosystems other
concepts
are out there for us to absorb
it's okay to adopt established best
practices from industry
it is true that there are many cases out
there and many of us got into functional
programming because we see problems
we've seen perhaps a local maxima where
java or c-plus plus can only get us so
far and then they get caught in some
kind of a trap and fp improves on that
those things are definitely true but
sometimes
they are
actually pushing forward good ideas and
we should be embracing that
that is the end of the talk
uh so now i will take questions which i
see some at least one is already coming
up
yeah
okay so one one question all advantages
and haskell in the current times is just
about better libraries for stm et cetera
couldn't other languages adopt those
libraries uh okay so stm in particular
is one that i really picked that i
really
picked on because stm really can't be
adopted by other languages without
fundamental changes it's true there are
other languages that have some level of
stm
but the real thing that makes stm as
powerful and hassle as it is
is the fact that we have purity and
since that's really the uh you know
that's the basis you can't just shoehorn
it into a language i think i could be
mistaken on this i think i heard that
the net team tried for quite a while to
add sdn into the net languages and
eventually they had to give up because
they really didn't have that purity
backing everything
so hopefully that uh that answers the
question if you have a follow-up let me
know
are there examples of concepts we can
learn from languages from other
languages or ecosystems i think overall
application design and structure is one
of the big ones uh
how to do logging you know some of the
very mundane boring things how to load
up a config file sometimes we in the
functional programming world
spend a lot of time reinventing the
wheel how to build code put it into a
docker image and ship it i see a lot of
the you know i spent a lot of my time on
the devops side of the shop also and
when it comes to functional programming
i see people really trying to reinvent
the wheel more often than we need to
there is another concept that i didn't
mention in the talk the concept of a
novelty budget and we should really pay
attention to
where are we getting the most leverage
the most the most power to rate the
power to wait to use that phrase again
what are the most powerful things we're
getting out of functional programming
focus on that
and use more standard techniques for the
other things
okay
it is definitely a long ways away but
could you foresee an fp language being
the first to mainstream quantum
computing i can definitely foresee it
but just to be completely honest i'm far
from an expert on anything relating to
related to quantum computing
uh so i would be very hesitant to say
something like that i would imagine
something like
you know monetic code applicative code
do notation i can imagine something like
that coming into play but i'm grasping
at straws so i probably said something
very stupid and people laugh at me which
is great go for it
okay
have you noticed any nice ideas that
hassle hasn't adopted yet that would
make the language even better uh
let's see oh and yes thank you for the
great talk comment thank you
uh
you know
recently i've been in the rust world
quite a bit and i think there are a lot
of ideas over there that are worth
adopting the one of the big things that
i've worked on in the haskell world is
my library called condor which is about
streaming data and i think it's great
and it's wonderful
but
it's
far enough away from the core
that you can't use it for everything
one of the things that really struck me
when i jumped into the rust ecosystem is
that iterators are such a fundamental
part of the language every single thing
in that language is built around
iterators down to four loops being built
on it and as a result you end up being
able to write very efficient
idiomatic code because everything in the
ecosystem supports it
i really believe that if we had
something along those lines probably
based on stream fusion but we had
something along those lines in the core
of haskell that could be a revolutionary
concept things like the fact that rust
has the vect type and vec is universal
again and everything is built on top of
effects and slices
instead in the haskell world we've got
strings and text and byte string and all
of these things are ever so slightly
different from each other so
yeah i do think that there are some some
great things to uh to learn
what do you think about java as p and
haskell can they learn from each other
i can't actually answer that question uh
just because i don't know very much
about the way fp is done in java i've
heard a few things i think even someone
in the chat mentioned streams
in java that's one of the things i've
heard maybe we could be learning from
and i think maybe some libraries in
haskell have learned from that
but overall i have to defer just because
the last time i did java in any kind of
serious way is probably 15 years ago
and
i got scared away just several seconds
the reason i ended up on the journey
that landed at haskell was i got scared
of uh
depending on spring mvc way back in the
day when you had to write massive xml
files to get anything done and i uh went
all over the place looking for a
different language stopped off at php
and parole and other surprising things
along the way and eventually ended up at
haskell
okay
uh oh is functional reactive programming
supported in haskell
yes there is there are functional
functional reactive programming
libraries in haskell i think there have
been some really cool innovations in
that space
i don't know how much they're being used
these days especially as approaches like
virtual doms on the front end have
really taken over
functional reactive programming i think
has taken a little bit of a dive
uh
obviously frp doesn't just have to be
for uis it can be for data processing
and other approaches as well
but overall it is it is supported i'm
just not up to speed on what the current
best practices are
that was an amazing session thank you so
much for sharing your experience with us
michael